So, to mitigate the shortcomings of a scatter plot, we can
plot the same data as a line chart, and connect the
dots with lines, as we see in this image. Putting lines
here really emphasizes trends. So, as we can see, there was
a pretty bad series of Red Sox teams in the 90s.
And that the Red Sox teams have been doing pretty well
in the 2000s. It's a little bit harder to see this
when we just have the points without the lines. That being said,
having lines that connect each point really puts
a focus on year to year variability. We
can see, for example that from 1964 to
1965, there's a huge drop. But it's a little
bit harder to have a good sense of
the more global trends. Are the teams getting better
or worse on average? For this reason, we
might introduce a lowest curve instead of these lines.